with South America
[Music]
flying over New York it is easy to understand
why there are so many tall buildings on the
small island of Manhattan here the only way
that enough room can be made for business
places and homes is to erect higher and higher
buildings many of these are called skyscrapers
the Metropolis of New York is actually made
up of several large cities the most important
of these cities within the city is the crowded
island of Manhattan where two million people
live another 3 million live elsewhere but
have jobs in Manhattan and every day hundreds
of thousands come to the city as visitors
in a crowded Metropolis like New York people
have difficulty in finding places to live
Park Avenue the city's best known residential
street is lined with tall apartment houses
another section of Manhattan has the largest
negro population of any community in the world
this is Harlem
in much of Harlem as in other parts of New
York families live crowded together in tenement
houses
some sections of New York such as the one
called Little Italy seem almost like communities
in a foreign land these neighborhoods were
settled by immigrants who arrived in New York
from countries in the old world others who
came later found life in the new world less
strange by living with those who could speak
their own language in Chinatown most of the
residents are people whose parents or grandparents
came to the United States from the far away
Orient
many different races and nationalities make
up the population of New York this Metropolis
has been called a melting pot because sooner
or later its people become Americans
in some parts of the city worn out tenements
are being replaced by groups of modern skyscraper
homes in these buildings hundreds of families
have their own separate sets of rooms called
housekeeping Apartments the crowded island
of Manhattan is but one of the five divisions
of New York City these divisions are called
Burrows besides Manhattan there are the Bronx
Queens Brooklyn and Richmond and for Miles
beyond the activities of the people are so
closely linked with New York that the entire
area is known as greater New York
a New York family wishing to occupy a single
house with even a small lawn or garden must
live miles away from the business district
communities surrounding the city are called
suburbs although in the suburbs of New York
homes are built close together families enjoy
more freedom and are not troubled by the noise
of the big city
the transportation of the millions of people
who go back and forth to Manhattan Island
every working day is a tremendous problem
people who do business in the city but live
in the suburbs are called commuters a great
many of these people make their daily trips
by train
morning and evening rush hours all means of
transportation are crowded with passengers
ferry boats run back and forth across the
rivers and Bays that surround Manhattan Island
most people who travel by ferry come from
communities in New Jersey and in the borough
of Richmond
before Bridges were built to link Manhattan
with the mainland ferry boats were the only
means of moving passengers and vehicles to
the island
today New York has the most elaborate rapid
transit system of any city in the world thank
you
because there is no longer room for tracks
above ground trains go underground into Subways
and tunnels as they approach the crowded areas
of the city tunnels have been bored deep under
the rivers and fast electric trains run on
tracks laid beneath streets and buildings
these underground Railways make it possible
for New Yorkers to get about the city quickly
moving stairs help passengers from the subway
stations far below ground to the level of
the streets
because Manhattan is an island a great many
bridges are needed so that Automobiles and
trucks can go in and out of the city
the George Washington Bridge spans the Hudson
River and connects the highways of New Jersey
with Express highways that run around the
island of Manhattan
New York's Express Highway is also connect
with tunnels constructed just for motor traffic
four great highways built under the rivers
lead from various parts of the Island to New
Jersey Brooklyn and Queens
these tunnels are used by Passenger cars buses
and by The Fleets of trucks which haul goods
and supplies for the minions who live in the
city
[Music] tons and tons of food are needed every
day for homes restaurants and hotels because
the land on Manhattan Island is too valuable
to be used for raising food everything in
the market comes from outside the city Farms
as far away as Oregon California and Texas
help feed the minions who live in the Metropolis
because there is little space for storage
in Manhattan Fresh Foods must be delivered
to Big Central Markets every day
okay
during the early morning hours produce from
all over the country has distributed to thousands
of smaller markets grocery stores and restaurants
at noon time streets are filled with lunch
hour crowds throughout New York's business
districts there are restaurants to suit every
taste and every pocketbook automats are cafeterias
where customers drop coins in a slot and in
return obtain food quickly
[Music] grouped around one short and Narrow
Street at the lower end of Manhattan are many
big Banks and investment firms the money that
comes to Wall Street belongs to millions of
people everywhere who have put their Savings
in bank accounts insurance policies stocks
and bonds these Financial companies provide
much of the money needed to carry on business
and to expand industry in the United States
as well as abroad
the money to build skyscrapers comes from
Wall Street firms that make a business of
investing money for other people the Empire
State Building cost many millions of dollars
to build and is the tallest structure in the
entire world this skyscraper is 102 stories
from top to bottom it provides New York's
crowded Midtown area with space for thousands
of additional offices and shops yet it occupies
less than one block of the city's valuable
land
the Chrysler Building has 77 stories and like
other skyscrapers provides headquarters for
big businesses that have offices all over
the country
the group of tall buildings at Rockefeller
Center is almost like another city within
the Metropolis
many of these buildings are occupied by radio
and television Studios advertising agencies
and insurance companies which serve the entire
nation people like these earn their living
by doing things which other people want instead
of making things
hundreds of people work for press associations
upon which newspapers all over the country
depend
but within the Metropolis of New York a great
variety of goods is manufactured the largest
industry is the making of all kinds of clothes
from underwear to fur coats more than a third
of all the clothing worn in the United States
is made in Manhattan's Midtown garment Center
this industry developed in New York chiefly
because great numbers of garment workers came
here from Europe
with them came dress designers and the city
soon became a Fashion Center the manufacturer
of a single garment may be done in several
different workshops in this heavily congested
District it is cheaper and faster to move
clothing from one shop to another in hand
carts
foreign
stores all over the country sell clothing
patterned after Styles seen in Manhattan's
most expensive shops New York like every Metropolis
is a great trading center upper Fifth Avenue
shopping district is the most fashionable
in the country many new styles are first shown
in Fifth Avenue stores
[Music]
[Applause]
the window displays of shops along 5th Avenue
are one of the principal attractions for most
visitors to New York
many dealers import expensive merchandise
from abroad While others specialize in fine
American-made products
whatever the world makes to sell can be purchased
in New York even the rarest of luxuries may
find a buyer among the minions who shop in
the city all right
[Music] just as the Metropolis of New York
is a center of Transportation industry and
trade it is also a great cultural center of
all its many museums and art galleries none
is more famous than the Metropolitan Museum
of Art
almost every day classes from some public
or private school visit the Metropolitan admission
to the museum is free of charge a great many
students attend art schools in New York in
order to make use of the city's many museums
The Collection owned by the Metropolitan is
one of the largest in the world it is a National
Treasure whose worth cannot be measured
it is almost a miracle that in the very heart
of crowded Manhattan Island an immense tract
of land has been reserved for a public park
come back
[Music] The Men Who planned for New York's
growth had great vision long ago they foresaw
the need for Central Park Manhattan's great
outdoor playground where the city's minions
now enjoy grassy spaces and the cool shade
of trees
[Music]
thank you [Music] but millions of New York
families live too far away from the city's
parks and playgrounds to visit them every
day the children whose homes are in crowded
neighborhoods have no choice but to make playgrounds
out of the streets
on hot summer days an opened fire hydrant
is the city child substitute for waiting in
a Cool Running Brook
and for older boys the swimming hole is at
the end of one of the city's hundreds of Piers
Coney Island one of New York's largest beaches
faces the Atlantic Ocean and is easily reached
by subway trains throughout the summer months
Coney Island is crowded with people seeking
relief from the sweltering heat of the city
at night the brightest reflection in the Skies
over New York comes from Manhattan the biggest
entertainment center in the world is the area
around Times Square and Broadway the great
white way within walking distance of Times
Square there are hundreds of theaters stage
plays and motion pictures here too of the
Opera the ballet and concerts
a metropolis is more than just one big city
it is a city made up of many cities that serves
not only its own people but also the nation
it is a great Center of Transportation industry
and trade where millions of people live and
work and play